violée par apple j'espère que vous allez
bien avant de commencer cette vidéo je
voulais vous remercier par rapport à
toutes les précommandes qui a eu sur les
fringues en fait qu'on a fait avec
traffic c'était assez stylé de recevoir
tous vos messages genre vouziers trop
content d'avoir les fringues
tout le monde était content de la
qualité enfin bref vraiment ça m'a fait
trop plein on a donc décidé de refaire
une collection et c'est celle que je
porte la marque saoudi super confortable
c'est le même coton bio que le souhait
de précédents essais la même qualité
j'aimais l'idée que vous puissiez le
maître de manière totalement sobre avec
un rien et du coup le logo c'est un
pin's donc vous pouvez l'enlever
alors vous allez me dire mais c'est
aussi j'enlève le logo en fait il n'ya
plus rien dans le pull ou quoi c'est
juste un pull gris que ça se passe que
vous voyez pas ce qu'il ya dans le monde
je vous présente badass socrates
donc on art design est en fait le
drapeau pirate avec un artiste en
mettant la tête de socrate papale la
philosophie est donc à la place des eaux
on a mis des colonies grecques tout ça à
la fois marrant à la fois cool j'aime
bien l'image que ça donne de la
philosophie en fait ça c'est pour le
souhaitent
et donc quand vous achèterez le
souhaitent y aura un pin's qui va avec
maintenant il existe aussi en tee shirt
et cette fois c'est pas dans le dos mais
c'est devant la sérigraphie est hyper
khalip et je trouve fort mais aussi je
vous mets tous les liens en descriptions
j'espère que ça vous plaira et c'est une
super manière de soutenir le projet quoi
quand je dis le projet je parle de la
chaîne et encore une fois merci à ce
qu'ils ont fait sur la collection
précédente
on passe un bon tiers de notre vie à
dormir c'est énorme et vous me
connaissez moi j'aime bien tout optimisé
j'utilise mon organisation ma manière de
travailler
montant de manière générale même chez
moi j'ai optimisé plein de trucs du coup
c'était juste une question de temps
avant que j'essaie d'optimiser mon
sommeil quand j'étais petit j'avais une
relation un petit peu compliqué avec mon
sommeil genre jeu mettait du temps à
m'endormir je voulais pas aller au lit
enfin vraiment c'était c'était chiant
quoi genre je voulais pas dormir et à
force j'ai vaincu sa rue j'ai une
relation vraiment top quoi déjà je peux
m'endormir à peu près n'importe où dans
n'importe quelle position
ce qui est très pratique en voyage je
pense que c'est une compétence qui
s'acquiert facilement quand on a un
enfant iranien je m'explique
en gros les enfants
nous emmène dans des soirées chez
d'autres parents aux iraniens et c'est
des soirées qui est dû un genre
excessivement tard genre 3h du mat et on
va pas rentrer juste pour coucher les
enfants non les enfants ils trouvent un
coin de canapé il se met sur les
manteaux et y dorment et se marrant
d'ailleurs parce qu'en fait j'avais pas
capté que c'était pas forcément comme ça
ce type de soirée dans absolument toutes
les cultures et en fait c'est une page
de même iranien qui parlait de ça et je
me suis dit ah mais c'est exactement mon
enfance quoi bref aujourd'hui je suis
très content de ma relation au sommeil
j'ai quasiment pas d'insomnie même quand
je ça va très mal dans ma vie et pour
vous dire
parfois je m'endors avant d'avoir eu le
temps d'éteindre la lumière ce qui est
ce qu'il fout quoi ça me tue quoi je me
réveille le matin je fais un j'ai
pas le temps d'éteindre la lumière
je me suis endormi avant et sachant que
je médite à chaque fois avant d'aller au
lit juste avant je pense que ça aide pas
mal
alors du coup ce sommet il a déjà l'air
pas mal comment l'optimiser et bien tout
simplement en dormant moins et pour ça
il ya une solution qui est tout trouvé
c'est le sommeil paul ifasic l'idée est
la suivante le sommeil qu'on connaît en
général il est mono physique austère que
on a un gros bloc de sommeil la nuit
entre 7,8 heures quoi le sommeil
politique
ça va être de découper ce bloc alors le
plus connu c'est le biphasique ça qu'on
coupe en deux il ya un gros bloc la nuit
il ya une sieste par exemple dans
l'après midi mais on pourrait s'imaginer
qui a pas qu'une seule sieste il
pourrait y en avoir deux trois quatre
cinq
en fait on peut découper ce bloc en
plein de blocs du pôle ifasic l'idée
c'est qu'en fait le corps s'épuise -
parce qu'il est debout pendant moins
longtemps et donc il a besoin de moins
de temps derrière pour récupérer
notamment parce que quand on dort c'est
les premières heures qui sont les plus
importantes c'est là on a le sommeil le
plus profond et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'il ya ce dicton qui dit que les
heures avant minuit compte double jeu
pas si vous êtes déjà entendu ça à mon
avis ça vient de là le soleil paul
physique est-ce que c'est nouveau
est ce que ces nouvelles tendances new
age qui vient de san francisco
pas du tout j'ai même lu je pense que
c'est une légende urbaine clairement que
léonard de vinci pratiques et leçons et
paul ifasic j'avais ça dans des vidéos
américaine des articles etc
j'ai pas pu retrouver la source du truc
et je pense clairement que c'est
n'importe quoi
je pense que c'est juste pour glorifier
un peu le mythe que ce soit du sommeil
politique ou léonard de vinci
après si quelqu'un à la source de cette
information je l'avais bien aux
commentaires par contre le son épaule
physique c'est potentiellement accès
vieux quand même genre homme de
néandertal
j'ai pas la source mais pour le coup ça
me semble un peu plus logique c'est que
en rouge lisait à droite à gauche que
l'homme de néandertal était
potentiellement passer d'un sommeil poli
physique un sommeil mono physique et ce
qui peut s'expliquer parce que en fait
avec les prédateurs avec le feu avec ce
genre de choses on ne peut pas dormir
trop longtemps d'une traite mais voilà
ça à prendre avec des pincettes et
d'ailleurs anecdote est ce que vous
saviez que de tous les primates
l'homme est celui qui dort le moins
d'après une étude de simpson et nous ne
savais pas ça je trouve ça assez fou
parce que je m'attendais presque
al'inverse en fait pour revenir au
sommet paul et basique beaucoup plus
proche de nous les navigateurs par
exemple d'autrefois et d'aujourd'hui
bah ils peuvent pas donc dormir sur de
longues périodes de temps donc il
utilise du sommeil poli physique donc
c'est pas un truc genre nouvelle vague
tendance type de productivité
il ya la base quand même j'ai donc voulu
l'essayer pendant 30 jours
alors finalement sa durée un petit peu
moins parce que ça devenait un petit peu
critique pour mon travail je vais venir
tout de suite il ya plusieurs façons
d'avoir un soyez polis fatick je vous ai
parlé du smi biphasique mais il ya
d'autres noms il ya par exemple le every
man 2 every man 3 et wii man 4 ou en
fait à chaque fois il ya deux siestes 3
sieste cat y est et est le team action
c'est une demi heure de sommeil toutes
les cinq heures et demies et il ya le
mythique huberman alors c'est pas du
tout celui qui va vous livrer de la
bouffe en vtc
non c'est un sommeil de 20 minutes
les trois heures et demie de mon côté
j'ai opté points every man 3 10 extended
en gros j'allais au lit à 23 heures je
me levais à 3h30 du matin
ensuite j'avais trois sieste dans la
journée de vingt minutes une à 7h20 une
à 11h50 et une à 16h45
il est 22h21 dans 40 minutes je me
couchais alain trois heures s'est très
tôt pour moi et je me levais ensuite à
3h30 c'est ma première nuit en sommeil
poli physique je pense que ça va piquer
ça va péter fort à 3h30 quand même
falloir se lever et surtout va pas
falloir se reprocher c'est ça qui est
difficile les trois heures trente et un
le réveil a été hyper d'où je suis un
peu fatigué mais
beaucoup plus qu'un réveil
normal quoi ce qui est un peu plus
bizarre par contre c'est ce jouet diva
voilà trois ans 10 au milieu de la nuit
et je vais pas me coucher en fait
l'expérience s'est faite globalement en
deux phases une phase d'adaptation et
une phase où j'ai vraiment pratiqué le
sommeil polyphonique la phase
d'adaptation
elle a duré quelques jours est en fait
mon problème c'était les siestes quoi il
est 6 heures 52
donc j'ai une première 6 aces dans à peu
près une demi heure là j'apprends d'un
petit peu les c est parce que j'ai
vraiment beaucoup de mal à juste dormir
20 minutes enfin du coup je pense déjà
au réveil qui est dans 20 minutes et
donc du coup plus le temps passe il faut
être plus de temps parce que je me dis
que tu as moins de temps donc en fait
faut que je dorme vite et donc du coup
ça me fout la pression et donc du coup
j'arrive pas voilà c'est ce qui se passe
en temps normal là j'ose espérer qu'en
fait je vais tellement crevé à force que
la sieste de 20 minutes à lasserre
facile et sachant que ce programme-là
every man 3 il est aussi fait pour que
va si je rate une sieste je vais c'est
ok je près celle d'après et celle
d'après ya peu de chances que je la rate
pas ce que je vais te crever bilan la
première journée franchement je suis
assez en forme pour après au lieu de
faire les trois sieste j'en ai fait deux
tons une le faire 20 minutes
j'ai fait une heure vingt je me suis un
peu endormi voilà je me suis réveillé
mais un réchaud rester au lit et en fait
du coup j'ai replongé jeune survivant
n'était pas au fond de trucs à retenir
quand je me réveille vraiment je sors du
lit tout de suite et là il est 23h 12
parce que je suis censé dormir à 23
heures donc voilà je vais dès qu'elle
est un petit peu le réveil et je vais
être un peu plus prévoyants pour bien
aller au lit à chaque fois à 23 heures
je veux c'est avoir cette régularité au
bout de quelques jours
j'ai réussi à faire comprendre à mon
cerveau que ok là tu as vingt minutes
pour dormir et c'est tout en fait très
vite au bout de quelques jours
genre je me réveillais même avant mon
réveil de 20 minutes là et je rêvais
dont je m'endormais
et je me réveillais tout ça en 20
minutes ce que je faisais c'est que je
mettais un minuteur de 25 minutes comme
ça j'avais le temps de m'endormir
sachez que c'est une compétence que j'ai
réussi à garder du sommet politique de
temps en temps petite sieste de 20
minutes aux petits oignons
on repart comme un air comme un lundi
mais pas du tout on repart c'est moi
l'expression
on repart
guingamp comme un poney fréquent - là
avant par l'art dont je pense pas je la
retrouvais un luron être fréquent mais
lyon frais comme un gardon
en effet à cette époque les familles
étaient nombreuses et une des seules
ressources en nourriture et était la
pêche le gardon et est un mets de choix
car sa conservation était supérieur à la
moyenne et il servait de référence en
fraîcheur lorsqu'on le comparer aux
autres poissons
c'est une vidéo sur le sol nippon et
basique et je suis sûr que l'information
qu'on retiendra tous ces cas un gardon
c'est un poisson et là on est le matin
du troisième jour c'est un peu compliqué
ce matin sortir du lit c'est un peu plus
chaud je serais bien resté dormir un peu
plus mais globalement ça va
hier j'ai bien maîtrisé les siestes je
crois c'est que je sens qu elles ont un
impact et ça agréable et voilà j'arrive
à tenir les 20 minutes
meiway ce matin c'est un peu compliqué
la seconde phase c'est la phase où
vraiment j'étais en somme époux l'ifasic
hélas très vite j'ai eu de gros
problèmes déjà c'est pas compatible avec
une once de vie sociale et je dis ça
alors que c'est le co vide où est ce que
je veux dire on n'est même pas dans un
contexte où on va sortir aller dans des
bars etc
quand même dans ce contexte là c'est
chaud j'en week-end chez tes potes et
c'est difficile de faire la sieste on
peut mieux la journée comme ça un point
est censé faire un barbecue est quand on
s'éclate au temps effectivement
est-ce que c'est chelou 2e de paris en
plein milieu d'un barbecue et les fans
sieste
personne ne fait ça c'est bizarre de
faire ça les serial killers peut-être
font ça ou alors si vous faites ça c'est
vraiment très suspicieux personne ne va
vous croire qu'elle est vous faire
pendant 20 minutes donc bref premier
point incompatible avec une vie normale
est ailleurs il ya beaucoup de gens qui
m'ont écrit parce que j'ai documenté
tout ça sur instagram et il ya des gens
qui m'ont dit je n'avais pas mais
en fait je fais du sommeil poli physique
et c'est des gens qui avaient des
rythmes de vie entre guillemets anormaux
cette étape de nuit ni des études qui
faisait qu'il révisait à tel moment à
tel truc mais dans un cadre de vie jordi
normal c'est une galère second point ma
qualité de vie
alors certes je dormais - mais tu as
déjà je me faisais réveiller quatre fois
par jour je déteste me faire réveiller
quatre fois par jour déjà une fois par
jour c'est beaucoup
quatre fois j'en peux plus je n'en peux
plus je fais une vraie nuit de sommeil
quoi j'avais juste aussi de rester dans
un lit en fait juste motif d'être dans
glee
la deuxième semaine donc ça fait huit
jours que j'ai commencé et ça me saoule
quoi ça me saoule je ne fais une sieste
ça valait 20 minutes j'ai dormi deux
heures ça me gave
en fait ça me gave parce que voilà j'ai
l'impression que ça allait mieux je
m'étais mis dans le rythme et il suffit
d'un week end où je suis pas fou le
sérieux ou un jour et j'ai tout perdu
donc ça demande une rigueur je suis
toujours pas adaptées là ça fait huit
jours je me suis toujours pas adaptées
en fait c'est relou c'est relou c'est
chiant ça m'énerve relâché neigeux
ronchonchon énervé le sommet c'est un
truc simple life salorges aller au lit
je me levais voir et 1,6 c'est devenu
hyper au louvre pour gagner deux heures
une heure deux heures par la charge
mentale que ça rajoute à ce que ça vaut
le coup le rythme est assez facile à
prendre en fait en fait une fois qu'on
arrive à faire les siestes de 20 minutes
donc ça c'est quelque chose que j'ai
réussi à maîtriser je pense au bout
d'une dizaine de jours
mais une fois qu'on arrive à faire ça le
rythme assez facile à prendre
je trouve là on est le 19 mars et donc
il est 7 heures 50
je vais les faire ma première c est de
la journée mais c'est fou parce que j'ai
déjà l'impression d'avoir fait une demi
journée en fait de taff quoi je
travaillé pendant trois heures et demie
et une forme de satisfaction de se dire
qu'en fait avant même que la journée
allait commencer ben on a presque une
demi journée derrière nous quoi et en
fait c'est super intéressant parce que
cette expérience elle a changé ma vision
générale du sommeil oui il est 10 heures
de philo souvent en trois parties les
suivent
la plupart du temps une d'electric
hégélienne et ben c'est ce que j'ai vécu
avec le sommeil grand 1
je suis ado je kiffe dormir je fais des
grasses mat je me réveille le dimanche à
14h en pyjama je me fais réchauffer un
plat surgelé et je joue à la console
voilà à ce moment là le sommeil c'est un
refuge c'est très agréable ça but mais
journée mais j'aime ça donc tant pis
grand 2 je suis un jeune adulte que j'ai
plein de projets
j'ai le feu en moi j'en vetra ces gens
et faire plein de trucs d'être productif
et c'est tout ça le sommeil à ce
moment-là ça un frein dormir me saoule
je passais un tiers de ma vie dans un
lit et s'est même pas pour baiser c'est
mort grand troyes la dernière étape et
c'est l'étape d'aujourd'hui
j'assume le fait d'aimer dormir c'est
une activité que je trouve non seulement
nécessaire mais en plus agréable j'ai le
droit d'aimer dormir ceni à un refuge
pour fuir ma vie ni un frein à ma
productivité
au contraire c'est ce qui me permet
d'être meilleur dans ce que je fais
c'est ce qui me permet de mieux
m'investir dans ma vie et en plus c'est
incroyable quand j'ai réalisé ça j'ai
arrêté la dernière semaine parce que je
commence à être en retard dans mon taf
en fait même si j'étais éveillé plus de
temps j'étais globalement moins
productifs
du coup c'était pas super intéressant je
pense néanmoins que dans certains
contextes genre d période assez courte
de temps genre de une ou deux semaines
ça peut être très intéressant de le
réactiver et je le ferai peut-être ça
dépend de ce que j'ai à faire
mais avec les petites siestes de 20
minutes là si vous arrivez à le
maîtriser c'est très très cool et
honnêtement je vous recommande donc
voilà rien que pour cet héritage des
siestes de 20 minutes je regrette pas
l'expérience et surtout une expérience
qui m'a permis de changer ma perception
du sommeil parce que visiblement j'avais
besoin de passer par là en tout cas le
sommeil poli physique c'est pas pour moi
je dois me lever je m'aime pas passer
deux fois au visage la vidéo va sortir
dans quelques heures et j'ai totalement
oublié de dire de faire un disclaimer ça
peut être dangereux soyez polis physique
en fait on sait pas sous les effets sur
le long terme de ce genre de ce mail à
donc voilà si jamais vous le faites
soyez conscient qu' on n'a aucune idée
des effets sur le long terme besoin nous
marchent pas rentrer dans les différents
stades de sommeil maystadt sous genre de
choses voilà je suis quelqu'un de très
pragmatique
mes expériences quand je les fais c'est
vraiment j'essaie de comprendre comment
je me sens quel est l'intérêt que ça
m'apporte et est-ce que c'est utile si
vous avez essayé le soyez polis physique
ou que vous pratiquez le sommet poli
physique vraiment hésité pas à partager
vos témoignages
en commentaire
hyper curieux de lire vos expériences ma
prochaine expérience elle sera plus
extrêmes
en tout cas pour moi puisque je vais je
vais laisser tomber le smartphone et je
vais me mettre au dôme faune pendant 30
jours
voilà ce sera l'occasion aussi de
prendre des distances avec cet outil qui
qui pèse un petit peu sur mon moral vous
en parlerai dans cette vidéo la d'ici là
prenez soin de vous montjoie la semaine
prochaine pour une question qui risque
de vous retourner le cerveau et je pèse
mes mots
encore une fois vous pouvez retrouver
ces fringues de qualité sur le site de
trafic
le bundle souhaite plus pin's avec un
gros socrates badass derrière et le tee
shirt c'est le même principe que la
dernière fois
c'est une précommande donc là la
production ne se fait que lorsque la
précommande est finie donc ça va durer
trente jours quand ces 30 jours sont
finis
là on lance la commande comme ça pas de
gâchis pas de stock etc et vous pour les
anciens pull et tee shirt bas il n'y en
a plus quoi parce que la précommande est
finie et donc on va pas refaire de
commandes c'est vraiment des collections
one shot à chaque fois je vous embrasse
très fort love peace now on met week end
la troisième semaine
aujourd'hui c'est le nouvel an iranien
deuil et mon réveil a lâché voilà j'ai
dormi avec quatre heures de plus et ben
c'était un kiff incroyable en fait je me
suis rendu compte que dormir c'est pas
juste un moment où je suis off et donc
où je peux pas faire des trucs c'est
aussi juste une activité en soit en fait
et je kiffe dormir j'aime ça en fait
j'aime dormir c'est cool de dormir parce
que pendant longtemps vraiment pour moi
c'était un blocage dans des activités
s'étaient ouais mais à cause du fait que
je doive dormir je dois pas faire si je
devais faire ça mais quel kiff de dormir
la faisanderie kfor de plus c'était
incroyable
c'était trop bien d'être un peu triste
qu'il ait fallu que je fasse cette
expérience pour moi en bronze mais bon
au moins je me rends compte